we are covering 10 new killer magsafe
accessories this gooseneck holder allows
you to easily mount your phone for a
variety of uses the sinjimoru m-band
quote that its magnet strength is more
than double compared to apple's magnet
they also make this wallet which is high
quality with strong magnets this mac
save duo ripoff instead of supporting
two devices it actually supports three
this is belkin's boost up charge pro
it's an upgrade to their older
three-in-one stand my next
recommendation is also from belkin and
it is their updated magnetic car vent
mount my next find is this thin aluminum
magsafe mount inker has this crazy arm
thing it does charge your phone and it
comes with everything you need in the
box this is anker's wireless charging
pack and it can actually charge your
phone about 30 percent more than apple's
solution the geoattack is a two in one
but your phone floats in the air and you
can charge airpods down below but of
course you won't get the fastest
charging speeds from it which is where
the caseology one comes in